so it turns out that there's actually a
part two to the Fox news interview that
Donald Trump did with Sean Hannity we
looked at part one yesterday and we are
going to look at a little bit of part
two today this is a part of the
interview that is significantly more
understated in tone but it is
significantly scarier to many of you who
have been emailing me and saying David
what exactly is Trump talking about and
is he really serious about this stuff
also of course raising questions of
Trump's cognitive State as is always the
case were they Freudian slips were they
brain glitches well we're going to
figure that out the second part of the
interview included Donald Trump
bizarrely claiming that he got rid of
NATO and built usmca now Sean Hannity
helps Trump out and then as you can see
Trump looks very confused Hannity helps
Trump out and says you mean NAFTA not
NATO you got rid of NAFTA and built
usmca but even that actually isn't
really much to write home about and I'll
explain that in a moment check out this
bizarre moment where Hannity quite
literally has to help Trump out of this
mess so if I made a lot of great trade
deals I changed a lot of those deals
where it was a bad deal for us now it's
a good like us MCA with NATO I got rid
of NATO and built usmca I made a great
job deal with China yeah our farmers are
to this day notice though that Hannity
tried to sneak in NAFTA Trump just
steamrolls it made tremendous money
because of the deal but because of covet
I don't even talk about that deal
because that overrid you know overrode
everything right so a completely insane
what Donald Trump is talking about says
he got rid of NATO to replace it with
usmca of course he didn't what he got
did what he did was replace NAFTA with
usmca a couple interesting things here
number one of course to some degree you
could say this is a Freudian slip Donald
Trump was one of the most hostile to
Nato American presidents and when he
says I got rid of NATO he would have
liked to get rid of NATO to have gotten
rid of NATO he didn't and instead he
just it's just a Freudian slip the other
aspect to this is that the continued
claim that replacing NAFTA with usmca is
some kind of major accomplishment it's
basically NAFTA with marginally
different Provisions about automobile
manufacturing with a new name and it is
true that usmca differs from NAFTA in
that it changes the requirements for
vehicle manufacturing what percentage of
the parts versus the labor needs to be
done where
but it is very similar to NAFTA and
again claiming it as some kind of big
legislative Victory is very very silly I
almost thought that it was like doctored
but it was just a Freudian slip I guess
uh Donald Trump also saying that if he's
elected here you know how Trump does
this thing where he can't help himself
he always has to make the promise more
grandiose and he has to make the claim
more grandiose there were 5 000 people
at my rally there were tens of thousands
there were tens of thousands and it's
probably double that he just can't stick
to reality he used to say he would fix
the Russian invasion of Ukraine on his
first day as president now he's saying
he would fix it even before taking
office which is again he's he always has
to go first I would fix that within
24 hours and if I win before I get into
office I will have that War settled 100
sure and everything I said yeah of
course that's not the case it doesn't
make any sense and Sean Hannity really
doing his best you know the hand
anything is interesting that this
two-night special interview with Donald
Trump
it does serve as evidence that at least
overtly Hannity is still on the Trump
train we know that Hannity was involved
in the Fox News text messages behind the
scenes that are part of the Dominion
lawsuit he expressed concern about some
of the things that were being repeated
he expressed concern about Sydney Powell
and so on and so forth but at least
publicly he seems to be very glad to
give Trump these total softball
interviews allowed Trump to lie lie lie
and present no pushback and so it's
interesting in the context of what is
the next year going to look like if
indeed this is a a heavily contested
primary right now I don't call the
Republican primary contested in the
sense that there are other people
running but it's Nikki Haley and Vivek
ramaswamy neither has a shot DeSantis is
polling pretty well but he's not
actually running so if DeSantis says I'm
running and if his polling doesn't
continue declining then we will say okay
now we've got a real primary on our
hands so far I can't really say that
that's the case Trump's Theory on
Chinese politics is that she is in
charge because the smartest person gets
to the top and I sort of think Trump is
trying to analogize to himself here
Trump sees himself as a very stable
genius and he seems to be analogizing
that also in the United States the
smartest person gets to the top as
evidenced by Trump having been president
for four years I think it's an age thing
I think a person running for
president you could even say running for
certain offices if you want to know the
truth now I don't know if it's
constitutional because people would say
it's unconstitutional but I would say
that if you could do it but I'd like to
see it for anybody running for president
I think somebody from running for
president taking a cognitive test you
know they do it in China but it's done a
different way
they have a caste system isn't that nice
guys the caste system of China will
allow you to figure out who is fit for
Duty and who is smart it I mean it's
it's not even sort of like uh but
benevolent dictator stuff it's just
straight up she is great China's caste
system this is wild stuff scary to the
rest of the world
and the smartest person gets to the top
shows and the media people and people in
the Press you've proven yourself
um at the highest level you can so Trump
just gushing about the intelligence of
she as well as the caste system
genuinely horrifying stuff lastly Donald
Trump tells Hannity there wouldn't have
been any Chinese spy balloons under my
watch and of course there were Chinese
spyballoons under Trump's watch and what
would you have done with the balloon and
what would you have done if Putin took
down one of your drones I wouldn't have
done anything with a balloon because it
wouldn't happen under me wouldn't happen
they wouldn't have sent the balloon if
this is a big balloon this is a balloon
where you can see it from it's like
three bucks 75 000 feet away people are
looking but it's rain to see it up there
we only found out because of a guy in
Montana they wouldn't have done it I'm
just telling you just like Putin would
have never gone into Ukraine so Trump
says they wouldn't have done it except
they did now it is true Trump didn't
find out about it until later that
that's absolutely true I'm not
pretending Trump knew about the balloons
when he was President we have now
learned that there were multiple
instances of Chinese spy balloons
overflying the United States while Trump
was President Trump's claim understand
is they wouldn't have done it if I were
president but they did it when you were
president he wasn't told there was some
kind of decision made
um by I guess it was the Pentagon that
it didn't need to get to Trump but they
literally did it while Trump was
president and he wants you to believe
they simply wouldn't do it if he was
president again
scary interview the romanticizing the
continued romanticizing of
authoritarians and wannabe dictators and
seeing them as just smart and great and
they've got these great systems they
don't have to deal with the Press they
just crush the Press they don't have to
deal with courts that might indict them
they just control the cords he loves
dictator type scenarios because he sees
them as the easiest thing for him if he
were to govern and he's not wrong
wasn't it George W bush who said it'd be
much easier if it was a dictatorship
um Trump seems to really want that